joining us with reaction texas senator
ted cruz senator
you've been down there you've been
warning everybody how bad it is
this is the biggest super spreader in
the country now i'm going to argue
you know the high rate of covert
positivity at that border
any american that is infected because
joe's not enforcing the laws of this
country
you can blame joe biden for covert and
if you die
i would put the blame on him too why
why won't they stop this super spreader
event
because it's happening in the hundreds
and hundreds of thousands
sean you're exactly right people across
the state of texas across the country
are pissed and should be pissed people
are dying
and joe biden doesn't care kids are
getting assaulted sexually assaulted
raped
and joe biden and kamala harris don't
care we've had over a million illegal
immigrants
in the last six months under joe biden
and kamala harris and they don't care
you take the city of mcallen releasing
seven thousand illegal immigrants into
mcallen
all of whom are positive with covet and
i put that in perspective
mcallen is the city its population is
about 141 thousand
that means five percent of the
population of the city
consists now of illegal immigrants
who've tested positive for kovid
that joe biden and kamala harris are
just dumping there one after the other
after the other
because they won't enforce the law and
instead what does joe biden do
he lectures the state of texas he
lectures the state of florida
he cannot stand that our states are open
he cannot stand
that our schools have been open he
cannot stand that people are going back
to work
he wants to get back to the jack-booted
thugs you had on bill de blasio this
morning i got to say
earlier tonight if the jack boot fits
these democrats they want to shut down
your business they want to shut down
your church
they want to shut down your school they
want to force you to get mandated
and all of this is wrong for americans
it's vaccine mandates it's mass mandates
it's vaccine passports
but for joe's illegal immigrant
population
is no testing high rates of covert
positivity
then you get to they're spreading it out
all over the country
um and and basically nobody gets a
vaccine nobody gets a test they get
processed they get then taken care of by
the states
states are responsible for food and
shelter education and health care is
that about right senator
that's right but it's even worse than
that the biden cages where they
temporarily detain these folks
i've been to them in these tent cities
where you have thousands upon thousands
of kids
packed in on top of each other crammed
in in unsafe
unsafe cages when when i was there a
couple of months ago i brought 19
senators with me to see firsthand
what was there the rate of covid
positivity was over 10 percent these
biden cages
filled with kids are covid incubators
and
and and all of these folks that lecture
self-righteously
about science they don't give a flip
about science because they wouldn't be
doing this if they did
they senator power and control if it
wasn't for you
they wouldn't let my cameras in those
facilities
you got that videotape you shared it
with this program
and if it wasn't for you and and a few
others
we wouldn't have been able to show
biden's overcrowded cages with kids on
top of each other in the middle of a
pandemic
with no testing but will take away the
rights of every american
whatever happened to medical privacy
doctor patient confidentiality
you you've argued before the supreme
court with a pretty high percentage of
winning many times senator
you tell me does that sound
constitutional to you
look the it it doesn't the left doesn't
believe in your privacy it doesn't
believe in your freedom and
and they try to portray it as an extreme
choice they
they say if you think people should have
individual choice
then you don't believe in science and
you want everyone to die no look
you i believe in science you believe in
science this is a dangerous disease
we've taken extraordinary steps
to deal with it when it comes to
vaccines i believe in vaccines i've been
vaccinated my family's been vaccinated
but i believe in individual choice i
think you have a right to make a choice
whether or not you want to take the
vaccine and you could measure the costs
and benefits
and in my view there should be no covid
mandates that means no mass mandates
that means no vaccine mandates that
means no vaccine passports
and and these authoritarian democrats
are wanting to mandate and force and
stick a needle in your arm
doesn't matter what you think doesn't
matter if you think you need it
as you noted they don't care if you've
had covid and have natural immunity
it's not about the science it's about
them controlling your lives
and the contempt they have for
individual americans making choices for
their own families
in times of crisis someone's character
is revealed
and i think biden and harris and and and
newsome and and cuomo and all of these
democrats
have really revealed their characters
joe
biden's policy is are are causing
americans to get sick
and i think if you look at the
percentages some of them will die
joe stop your super spreader event
enforce the laws and control the border
senator cruz thank you for being with us